Sidda welcomes I've done outside the
episode and a lot of you guys do some
thinking where's your theme song you
always forget to put it in
[Music]
just to throw back to the good old days
so one of the top questions that I saw
in my ass IG a request for questions was
just seen what is wrong with your
MacBook Pro what do I think about it a
lot of stuff regarding the MacBook Pro
because I sent a tweet the other day I
was losing my mind because I was trying
to edit all I was getting was a beach
ball and I felt like my computer was so
slow that he was putting me in a
position that I started how do I even
say I don't even know if I should say
that well did I say it out loud and it
becomes true
and if I say it out loud then it's out
there for the Internet to hear the words
that I was thinking alone and in my
corner of my office so I have a PC for
gaming and my friend Matt just recently
got a new computer BEC to the max maybe
I need to spec out a PC I love Final Cut
and I just don't know if I could leave
it but I was troubling he's so hard to
edit a simple video that I was like I'm
an extremely fast editor with it I add
it really quick I still edit all of my
own videos and I get things done quite
quick I'm pretty efficient everything
was lagging but I would be five steps
ahead Oh what I was editing I would have
already made a cupped deleted the
previous clip and done something else
it's new trying to catch up good not
what it should be
I spent this freaking thing out I paid
$5,000 for a laptop I bet it's a nice
table do something do something I do
what I tell you to do like freaking just
hi in front of my eyes I am unusually
epitome Apple user like I don't want to
be having these thoughts guys like it's
not good
I mean it's a new machine at the first
Jam you mean things happen I just don't
like it and the issues I had with like
the Mac Pro you know I don't want to be
I don't want that again I don't want
that again I'm just really sad I mean we
have much bigger issues right now but
that's not what about what about this
issue is this just a meat problem am I
being sabotage a move on to the next
question because I can't be having a
conversation right now because I'm
supposed to be shooting a video you know
you guys don't come here for complaining
you come here to be uplifted this is how
I'm feeling I'm feeling belly not hurt
with all that being said like I still
continue to use it because it's a really
nice machine like it looks good it's
small compact I've finally got over the
fact that I have to use dongles
I lost my initial dongle that I first
bought for it so I'm already on my
second dongle I'm unable to focus right
now Matthew is asking me what keeps me
motivated to do YouTube so I guess I
answer that question I think you guys
essentially are the motivating factor I
love creating videos I love having
conversations because this is sort of my
outlet for creativity and I basically
can do whatever I want like I'm 100% in
control and that's basically all I've
ever really wanted I guess growing up
sort of in the middle of nowhere not
really having a lot of friends I felt
like I wasn't being heard I didn't have
people around me to connect with and
because I basically was in the middle of
nowhere
I mean thankfully I had an amazing
family growing up so I feel like my dad
is one of the huge reasons that I've
gotten into technology because he's
super tech savvy always doing things
fixing things and he completely built
our house from the ground up and wired
everything and anytime I have a problem
I'm like that how is fix Tiffany fixes
it it's like magic what he didn't knows
how to do things like my mom always was
super supportive of all of the random
things that I really like to do like I
liked playing video games I even asked
her a long time look well why did you
buy me a Nintendo in that way why well
that's the one thing that you wanted
really really badly but noise a lot of
parents sometimes
supportive of playing video games cell
thankfully as long as I got these and
grades my mom let me play video games
she let me use my computer
of course I sometimes wasn't allowed I
got bad grades but honestly getting good
grades was the only motivating factor
because if I did not make good grades
then I got my precious computer in my
precious video game taken away from me
not that I couldn't get the good grades
just like I had a priorities I'll fix
playing video games and study all play
has a long-winded answer was you guys
essentially keep me motivated I enjoy
doing this and I swear to you yes this
is a job but if I wasn't having fun
doing it I would not be doing it I get
to make fun and creative videos for you
that I mean some of them aren't that fun
or creative I still get to connect with
you and have a conversation and it's fun
is a lot of fun also a lot of work so
having YouTube channel unless you have
editors and someone to shoot and do
everything for you it's a lot of work
just once no on a scale of 1 to 10 how
presidential was my day I wasn't very
presidential and I do a lot of fights on
Twitter and I'm guys stop everybody has
an opinion and here's the thing everyone
is entitled to their opinion until they
don't agree with your opinion then it's
like well your opinion doesn't even
matter anymore because I have my own so
what I've been trying to do recently is
respect to everyone's opinion and just
don't even say anything because a you're
never right on the internet you're never
right to just basically just shut your
mouth just just shut it got to go back
to what I said before do your parents
think it's funny in hindsight how
obsessed with computers you've been
since you were younger I do of course
she has to have hidden keyboards because
my mommy's tied keyboard if I didn't get
good grades I think they do find and
make it funny and you know I think sort
of letting your kids have sort of
somewhat of enough freedom to sort of
choose their own path as long as it's
sort of going in a good direction that's
what you have to do because honestly I
feel like telling people and talking at
them and telling them what they need to
do or what they should be doing or what
you have to do or just doesn't give you
that free to freedom to sort of find
yourself so for the most part
listen your parents those schools do the
things they tell you but also keep in
the back of your mind one day you're
going to be able to be old enough to
make your own decision and what it's
time to actually make those decisions
you're going to go back and be like wow
my mom or my dad or my grandmother or my
aunt whoever it is is your main person
that you look up to or your guardian
you're going to do it Wow
you're right I was wrong we gotta learn
for yourself just having someone tell
you things
you're just not gonna lose you just
gotta experience it but just know most
the time the right which adherence
performed Y like better shape of you or
castle on the hill
I actually prefer shape of you a lot
more than casual meal I like asking on
the hill but I feel like shape of you
has got a nice little beat to it kinda
reminds me exactly like see a song oh I
love those so Jay Ryan wants to know
which book I would recommend on audible
this month some of you guys have already
read this book or you've already bought
it on audible but if you haven't I
recommend it because I just downloaded
it and this book and joslyn would love
and first sight doesn't I did a really
fun collab video where we make you book
in - okay wow this is great work inside
here deal with the book inside we're
going to chicle is enough oh yes
it worked out fairly well now I've got
his book inaudible you guys want to
check out this book or any other book
you guys feel free to use my code
audible.com slash Augustine and you guys
will get a 30 day free trial you'll also
get one free book at a chance to check
that audible and this has been such a
stay here for me for flying and
traveling because this is a new
information I highly it is this every
single time but it's like someone is
reading to me and Josh said that in his
book he didn't actually read this one so
he had someone actually read it and fun
notes I did narrate my book and
reporting an audiobook was probably one
of the most difficult things that I've
ever done so I hope that anybody who's
listened to my audio book you appreciate
it because man the struggle was real
anyway let me know what book you guys
get for this month and again definitely
check out Josh's book if you don't get
it on audible you've gotta get it
somewhere I'll calm slash iJustine check
it out and I'm going to start looking
the best it's only 6 hours and 25
minutes that's basically a flight and a
half across the country am I going to
edit these tweets and put them in a
video or just read them I'm pretty sure
I'm going to edit them in I usually do
that Lily wants to know what Mario's
best powerup is oh I love the raccoon
hat that's always been my favorite like
Aetna likes romário 3 nothing really
came in handy Rhonda wants to know if my
hair is still rose gold because you
can't really see it in my video it's
very hard to tell I only wanna walk come
on my hair is I basically was trying to
do a very small process of going back to
my natural color which is all of this up
here and this just kind of leads into a
nice ombre and if you're wondering what
I'm looking at I have a longer that's
sitting right off the side here so I'm
essentially looking at myself to make
sure that I'm in focus and Frankie my
pal is it still do we still see some red
uh Who am I getting is gone it's gone I
like my hair darker so that's the good
news
Manu wants to know if I'm excited about
the Nintendo switch yes I'm super
excited I preordered the neon version
and it's going to be interesting to see
how people use this because my plan is
that all my friends come over and bring
them to attend of switches and we just
sit and play video games
I can't wait it's going to be great just
as if you're a really cool picture of me
so thank you so much I think it's very
very nice you guys are super talented if
you guys do any sort of illustrations or
drawings or anything please send them to
me because I love looking at them I
actually really wanted to be an
illustrator when I was younger I love
drawing and I wasn't very good I mean I
was an awful but it was just sort of one
of those things that I kind of
gravitated more towards digital I used
to love being a digital illustrator I
used to drop so much stuff in
Illustrator Adobe Illustrator
I got make sure I'm still recording yes
we are sometimes this camera turns off
and I don't know it and then I lose half
of a video well that was actually my
last question that I had saved so thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
actually some questions in the comments
below let me know what audible cue
clocks let me know how you're doing if
you're having a good day and please
remember the only thing I asked is just
English in the comments like be kind to
each other not just on the internet but
in real life
please don't for me do it for yourself
do it for your friend with your neighbor
I don't think in the next video this
much is so incredible but I can't I
can't get it to close oh there we go
okay I just in try our enough hmm
the first you don't succeed try try try
it again I mean I know together how to
do this probably should feel nice just
remember where we go
remember when we did
[Music]
now